salut à tous je suis envergure en vidéo
mais ce sera évidemment aujourd'hui au
programme ou petite analyse moudre aux
58 de la draft pour des analyses il faut
des analystes
donc c'est une fille envergure vous le
voyez notre romain leroy il est de
retour
comment vas-tu romain je voulais voir
ton en alsacien mais je vois pas donc ça
va 132 matches joués cette saison 2 2
finale fort et une saison beaucoup trop
long coutts avant impôts dgi je rappelle
pour l' île dupas salut les copains je
suis désolé 1 je suis ravi mais comme
d'habitude dans la rédac de soyez pas
surpris si y'a des gens qui viennent se
demander ce que je sois pas de [ __ ]
les gens qui font wimbledon à côté ils
comprennent pas trop ce qui se passe on
va pas parler tennis 1 aujourd'hui mais
mais on va parler justement de la draf
alors d'habitude fois en vidéo montre
maire de redescendre d'un échange avec
nous tu rigoles tu rigoles je pense que
toni kukoc serait flatté d'avoir pris
les devants drôme à l'euro à minima vim
avant de commencer juste un petit cadeau
petites annonces
on peut on peut dire que vous serez tous
les deux le soir de la draft
on peut on peut si c'est à moi que tu
poses la question en tout cas oui la
draft raccordables en live sur ville 28
au soir on sera avec romain
techniquement aussi si peu skipper et
j'espère avec avec beaucoup comme d'hab
pour refaire la team qui avait ça l'an
dernier donc voilà on va revivre
ensemble cette belle soirée avec romain
c'est magnifique voilà une très bonne
nouvelle qu'on vous annonce une nouvelle
fois honoré de l'invitation géant vers
10 heures une petite expertise sur le
bateau via via ce beau gosse de romain
alors 7 29 juillet voici sa part
naviguer graves sur bin sport nous on
sera sèche et la force brute
maintenant qu'on a fait les
présentations jeu de rôle graf
on va faire comme si on était le soir de
la draft romain et réunis vont être les
décideurs des franchises donc romain
auxerre jean prat xiaoting rémy sera
plus coté general manager donc celui
vraiment valide la décision à la fin moi
je serai modestement adam silver 3000
pratique avant d'y aller
roman est ce que tu peux juste en
dessous de dire que fait le directeur de
strauss
quelle analyse ils apportent quelle info
le directeur du scouting chez chu qui va
prendre qui va prendre des décisions
avec le front-office qui va centraliser
les infos un petit peu et qui va soit
faire le bon choix soit faire la bêtise
pour faire simple je suis qui est payé
pour faire soit le bon choix soit la
bêtise en eau dans certaines franchises
dont celle dont on parlait tout à
l'heure donc comment s'enregistrer c'est
plutôt des bêtises dans d'autres ça peut
être parfois des bonnes décisions donc
voilà c'est un petit peu le le rôle
après d'une franchise à l'autre vous
avez soit directeur du scouting sur les
600 gm qui est directement dédiés à
sable une organisation à l'autre ça peut
varier un petit peu mais de la chine a
dit eller on ne citera évidemment par
rémy toile ogm donc on va demander un
peu plus d'avoir un oeil sur l'ensemble
des composantes du club l'ex coach donné
ce contexte le jauger ce qu'un choix de
draft
c'est quand même un mélange entre autres
évaluer un talent et le placer dans un
bon contexte afin de maximiser premier
choix de draft romance détroit
pound pistols donc réuni 3 wheeler et tu
as le premier choix et c'est partit
alors par l'humour de détroit et se s
comprend tout simplement notre premier
choix se comprend deux meilleurs talents
disponibles ou est-ce qu'on se pose des
question d'alchimie celle et c'est
l'éternelle question déjà avec ses
pistols cc1 bizarrement pour une équipe
qui a un premier pic pas l'équipe qui a
le plus de besoins remplir j'ai
l'impression
c'est une équipe qui a des pièces qui
sont en train de se mettre en place qui
part de loin en termes de construction
mais quand même il ya des trucs dans
cette équipe chez les pistons il ya là
de géra migraine en simili franchise
player pour l'instant il ya des jeunes
joueurs il ya sadique bay acquis d anaïs
qu'on va vouloir voir sur une saison
pleine donc voilà il ya des choses
intéressantes
moi j'ai l'impression quand je regarde
l'effectif là dedans qui manque déjà de
scoring pure et j'ai l'impression qu'on
manque de celui qui devra à court ou
moyen terme est le franchise player de
cette équipe il faudrait trouver un
talent avec un premier pic de draft qui
dans deux trois cinq ans max pourrait
emmener cette franchise vers les
play-offs et plus haut oui parce que tu
as dit simili française hier donc ça
manque donc le alpha dog romain think i
1 qui est candidat selon toi sur le
premier sur le premier choix cette année
je pense qu'il ya un consensus global on
peut pas forcément aller ailleurs que
sur quelques lignes âme parce que sur ce
qui peut apporter notamment sur le
scoring les capacités devenir fan chasse
player ça me parait ça me paraît faire
sens voilà ça peut scorer sado gagner un
petit peu en en création mais c est le
billard et dit même s'il même si
athlétiquement il ya des petites
questions
malgré tout c'est un malheur de jeu
admettre qu'ils étaient leaders de son
équipe et est qu'il ya des cas des
choses à faire valoir
difficilement faire autrement que sur
quelques lignes je pense à mi-temps à la
draft
c'est que dans un mois ça fait un moment
qu'on le prenait avec penny williams
valide la vallée bleue fois j'ai
évidemment pas votre expertise en terme
de scouting des mecs mais sur koné
guingamp
- ya consensus ça a l'air d'être le fort
talent est assez loin de ce que je
comprends dans cette classe donc c'est
très difficile de passer à côté pour une
équipe comme détroit qui a besoin de
talents toute façon donc oui je valide
évidemment très bien - côté sajoo avec
la balle mais il sait jouer oscille sans
ballon non certains vont peut-être voir
ça comme une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
nike pas vraiment de cet avis l'avenir
nous dira en tout cas c'est une favori
pour une force parce que vous avez
choisi deuxième du chrono astronautes là
il ya un peu de questions sans doute
avez vous tué raphaël stone ne
deviennent des houston rockets et c'est
partit alors parlons des perroquets
besoin mon dieu mon dieu mon dieu alors
là c'est pas le même cas de figure que
détroit parce que pour le coup tu as
besoin de quasiment tout mais vraiment
de tout alors ça me fait si on prend ce
qu'il ya dans l'équipe aujourd'hui
puisqu'on sait qu'elle a été
complètement explosé cette équipe avec
le départ de james harden l'an dernier
et encore john wall qui est là dedans
moi ça me fait mal au coeur parce que
j'adore ce mec mais john wells et c'est
de la chair à canon dans le sens où dans
l'immédiat pour eux c'est la matière a
trahi il faut pas construire cette
franchise autour de john wall je vois
pas ça arrivait dans ce qui reste une
fois que on se libère de john wall d'une
façon ou d'une autre je vois deux
joueurs majeurs ou que tu auras du mal à
traiter ou tu as peut-être regarder
série coordonne et christiane woods qui
sont des pièces intéressantes dans des
registres différents
et du coup alors s'il faut cibler un mec
parce qu'il faut bien cibler un mec sur
ce deuxième pic mois j'identifie deux
besoins principaux à houston de la
défense dans la raquette du poste du
poste 4-5 défensif ce n'est pas
christiane woods clairement et du shoot
extérieur c'est une équipe ça fait
bizarre de dire ça pour houston mais qui
a besoin de shoot extérieur
donc voilà l'un des deux besoin que
j'aimerais remplir avec ce deuxième but
mais peut-être avant tout du talent
pardon je j'aurais dû commencer par là
mais ça va sans dire que cunningham sera
plus disposent donc si j'ai le deuxième
plus gros talents bruts jeu peut piquer
quasiment sur tous les postes créés jeu
j'en aurai besoin de façon kevin porter
junior est toujours là bas
oui je sais ça fait partie des joueurs
intéressants c'est un peu un peu
valdinguer
roy lé kom profil avec déjà le deuxième
au talent et ensuite peut-être voilà le
deuxième plus gros talent et
intelligence en défense et pour moi de
ce que j'ai vu de ce que j'ai regardé ce
matin un petit peu evans meublaient
peuvent faire sens c'était pas forcément
dans la peinture qu'elle accuse de
besoin mais son profil un petit peu un
petit peu longe il y avait une vraie
agitée et même si l'on savait pas
forcément encore assez l'épaule sur
certaines choses et ça se désunit un
petit peu c'est intelligent en défense
ses 16 points 8 rebonds avec avec you et
si c'est de mettre 13 et de 26
d'envergure je pense qu'elle a les
arguments à faire valoir
cergy si on part sur le ratio talent
brut potentialités et éventuellement
capacité à se projeter rapidement je
pense que je pense que me blesse à peu
ça peut faire sens sur le profil un
petit peu post 5 ans j très mobile ça
peut être intéressant dans dans une
équipe de houston ont je cherche encore
un petit peu donc voilà cc c'est pas des
collants sur le deuxième choix evans
mobley donc pour pour le deuxième choix
rémy c'est valider ça fait ça comme l'un
des besoins on va parler de tout à
l'heure j'ai ce besoin là qui est
comblée j'ai un talent à priori
important sur ce deuxième piquet
j'aurais perdu tous les étages toute
façon que je valide le choix des vannes
bouclez vos choix numéro trois dans la
peau de voeux de kobe altman cette fois
puisqu'on parle direction les caves donc
la kenyane est parti je rappelle evans
mobile est parti en 2e ligue
les caps trény qu'est ce que pour toi ou
on doit doit rechercher cette franchise
est ce qu'on a toujours besoin d'un bon
super start histoire alors c'est une
bonne question là pour le coup à
cleveland
autant les deux premiers choix déjà
précieux qui sont faciles à effectuer
autant à cleveland il faut se poser des
questions il va falloir faire des choix
justement déjà dans l'effectif actuel
quand tu regardes qui a qu'est ce qu'on
fait de kevin love est ce qu'il ya une
décision qui est prise à un moment et ce
pour se décider à se séparer de kevin
love est ce qu'on arrive à ses parents
kevin love ou parce c'est important le
deuxième choix qui va être important
c'est c'est ce qu'on croit vraiment
toujours
duo d'arrières la folie de sexton darius
garlande moi la seule valeur sûre
vraiment sûr dans son roster qui me
plaît c'est isaac okoro drafté l'année
dernière qui a été bon
clairement si pour x ou y raison l'une
des deux premières franchises vont pas
sur evans mobile et ça peut me plaire
parce que parce que parce qu'il va
falloir redoubler ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur
mais si comme tu l'as dit evans mobile
et plus dispo je me demande s'ils
seraient pas tant de faire sauter le duo
sexton garlande sans doute en gardant
sexton j'imagine
et encore je m'aime pas sûr et pourquoi
pas prendre prendre prendre à notre un
autre combo à notre arrière ça moi ça
pour ça pour être l effectivement c'est
vrai que c'est une option n'a pas
forcément pensé toute façon va partir
draps dans la période des rumeurs si tu
veux prendre si tu veux rester sur ce
sur ce possible duo d'arrières tu as la
solution déjà les seuls qui aient pas à
quel paquet pas inintéressante parce que
joueur leader dans une jeune équipe qui
est quand même reconnu pour son jeu
globalement à gonzaga fort sur les
changements de rythme ainsi plus encore
turn over promeneurs ce qu'il peut faire
et perd encore un petit peu la balle il
ya des aspects of offensive jeudi à
améliorer mais dans l'idée je pense que
ça peut ça te cite avec 6 tonnes c'est
un joueur qui peut jouer sur les deux
postes arrières bon pas forcément de
gros gros shoots à trois points mais des
choses à des choses intéressante quand
même est une équipe qui était loin sur
le tournoi final dont quelqu'un qui qui
sait gagner aussi et je pense que dans
une équipe comme clivante qui seront
construits
avoir un joueur qui est habitué à gagner
un petit peu et qui sait comment gagner
au niveau universitaire c'est pas
inintéressant de de mettre ça dans la
dans la balance lui celui que john green
donc alors on explique rapidement mais
en gros le deuxième panier de talent au
niveau des joueurs il ya une gamme qui
est au dessus et ensuite il ya un groupe
de froid modeler broughton en tout cas
c'est ce qui est vu par la part des
observateurs
je suis je suis plus sereine parce que
green ya quand même
un côté vision un petit peu tunnel à
certains moments qui associait sexton ça
peut faire beaucoup ça peut faire un peu
duo derrière un peu kamikaze préféré
quelqu'un capable de ne plus jouer sur
les deux positions et d'avoir un j'ai
rappelé un accueil glacial plus élevé
parce que le terme serait dur mais
quelqu'un qui puisse apporter un peu
plus de 2,2 balance dans le sur la ligne
arrière
c'est mon choix je peux dire une
connerie mais voilà après on va vers
rémy la confusion aussi c est ce que si
on veut absolument evans mobley qui
apporterait de la sérénité à l'intérieur
renouvellement de ses lignes 9 et ce
qu'on peu près dé aussi d'une position
qu'on va aller chercher le bullois
cleveland a beaucoup de cette marge de
manoeuvre
après la question de la marge de
manoeuvre il est toujours ses compensées
par les valeurs de contrat le l'atout
numéro 1 qui vendent est ce que c'est un
atout d'ailleurs où un poids c'est kevin
love aujourd'hui s'attaquent eux kevin
love ya un moment ou un autre si tu le
mets dans un package a fallu obtenir
quelque chose en retour
tu as le troisième pictes à kevin love
est ce que ça peut pas obtenir son
deuxième victime et du salaire
contrebalancer j'en sais rien après si
tu décides de te séparer de darius
garlande ou de colis de sexton ça reste
des gamins qui ont de la valeur
aujourd'hui c'est des gamins courent un
potentiel je pense que tu as moyen de
package et pour monter d'un pic dans la
draft pour aller chercher gbagbo
après ce que houston inter aller
chercher d'une des surnuméraires en
arrière sauf si la question
voilà s'échangeront de quasiment 8 en
tout cas donc que tu valides de notre
ami seul l'arrière donc mineur un peu
plus gestionnaire bon ça va
dans l'hypothèse où on fait sauter cette
espèce de deux bases arrières chelou la
autres sextoys et garonne ok alors
partons là dessus et on va il est tout
petit sur le pwa numéro 4 tu vas être
dans la peau de bobby webster n'avons
pas ce que c'est
toronto qui a fait le bon coup de la
loterie quand même et non tu en sois
numéro 4 alors toronto ça une situation
très particulière quand même pas par
rapport à une équipe qui normalement
quand ton piquant 4/10 on a on a plus de
trous à combler de sa proie oui tu as
raison c'est à ce que tu as dit c'est un
coup de chance incroyable de piqueyrot 4
pour pour pour toronto et tant mieux
pour un il en faut de temps en temps au
site
ils sortent on sort du coup les raptors
d'une année étrange c'est cette année un
peu un peu bizarre de ne sait pas trop
si c'était une année de transition pas
de transition ça jouer à tampa c'était
il ya eu trait d'apporter de kyle lowry
on la traite deadline et où enfin tout
ça c'est un peu bizarre cette année à
toronto
moi il me semble qu'il faut commencer à
préparer à préparer l'après kyle lowry
il sera free agent l'âge on sait pas ce
qu'il va faire personne ne sait ce que
va faire kyle lowry il va intéresser du
monde
je pense qu'il faut préparer l'après
kyle lowry est allé chercher un meneur
ou un combo pierre plutôt un mineur
parce que des arrières j'ai l'impression
que tu en as déjà un meneur pur dans
cette draft
ça me fait du bien je pense un mineur
vraiment combler un trou qui tu as
peut-être descend en marchant talent jeu
je te vois venir je te vois venir qui à
johnson non ben jawad ce que je pourrais
faire sens là aussi par rapport par
rapport au profil qui auraient sinon
derrière si on part sur 2 sur dur du
meneur pur on accueille johnson mais qui
est peut-être plus limité en plus limité
en talents dont moi je suis je souhaite
c'est perso forcément
ouais c'est c'est un combo puis moi je
suis pas je suis pas forcément un un
grande fan il faudrait que je creuse
encore un petit peu
sinon il ya la solution la solution
sharif cooper qui peut qui peut
également dans un rôle de meneur scoreur
apporter quelque chose
encore très limitée dans le tir à trois
sapeurs cannes ballons par match parce
que ça part un peu dans tous les sens
mais bon est-ce que c'est presque que
c'est pas en terme de talent brut le
simple le plus simple de la solution la
plus rapide à voir sur mon seul qui
n'est pas forcément disponibles et que
les tièdes jeunes somme me rassure pas
forcément il ya le le côté choisir du
talent aussi
on a entendu déjà des rumeurs de trade
eu ce tir calmes que les warriors
voudrait aller chercher il ya des
combinaisons sont possibles et ce que si
est ce que il est envisageable quand
même rémy de john booth le meilleur
talent disponible et enfile devoirs ou
bien sûr parce que cette franchise parce
que quand je te dis que l'on sait pas
trop ce que c'était cette année de
transition ou pas c'est que c'est le
genre de situation tu sais les
franchises se pose des questions et
marshall opportunité c'est à dire que là
il n'y a pas de chemin évident pour que
toronto redevienne un conteneur pour un
titre nba dans les 50 moi j'en vois
partout donc il faut sauter sur les
opportunités
si t'as pas
si t'as rien qui se propose à toi cet
été comme tu disais une opportunité de
trading et wario tu t'y faire sauter le
groupe et se séparer de sa gamme ça peut
s'étudier clairement si t'as pas ça et
battu draft oui le talon le plus fort ça
peut être ça peut être la solution la
plus simple aussi et dans ce cas là on a
du bien aussi ce que tu barnes est pas
mal moi ce qui me les deux choses qui me
gêne avec scotty barnes et sont un jeu
lancé qui est catastrophique
ce qu'il doit être à 62% ou quelque
chose comme ça on est pas sur des
valeurs crise de la lèze joue la
recherche de leur chère à rémy mais on
est quand même pas voilà et derrière il
ya surtout il ya pas de tir extérieur et
c'est peut-être un peu limite c'est à
dire que ça va être un vrai profil
intéressant mais ya pas de y'a pas tirs
extérieurs derrière j'aime beaucoup ce
côté barnes mais ça me paraît encore un
petit peu il est lire et 10 sur le corps
mais il ya encore des choses à
développer que donc avoir de l'amour
je garde je garde garde à l'oeil la
rumeur je m'éloigne wright à toronto si
tu veux c'est plus une rumeur qu'autre
chose mais mais j'aimerais cueilli
chariot trouve un spot donc si ça peut
être à toronto qui le suit depuis
longtemps pour mieux y a pas d'infos non
non c'est juste une rumeur c'est juste
que j'ai vu passer ces derniers grands
j'en ai parlé avec lui
déjà il ya l'intérêt de plusieurs
équipes nba sur lui et c'est de ce côté
là c'est justement on va y a des infos
qui s'appelait bonbons prenez qui les
décideurs à binche
écoute moi si je veux si je veux mon
après si je veux mon après calories
compare pas sur l'idée de faire exploser
l'équipe parce que bob shaye dancers
dahico pas tarder à faire mais on l'a
bien pris en 3 à brad geoffrey les
parties balfe sauront pas je m'en remets
à mon directeur du scouting moi je veux
un vrai bonheur
dans ce cas dans ce cas là on part sur
j'arrive cooper avec le risque et le
risque sur le côté un petit peu encore à
comment dire ah ah polje en terme de jeu
mais sur les meneurs pur c'est ce qui
reste de dispose qui voilà pour moi il
apporte plus de garanties qu'ils à
johnson ne serait ce que sur le scoring
j'adore le risque sharif hooper anclades
j'adore ça aucune ya rien de rationnel
dans ce qu'on fait c'est pas avant
s'enflamme c'est pas là mais moi moi moi
j'aime beaucoup ça arrive cooper et pour
avoir regardé les matchs au lycée il
shootait bien mieux à auburn ou n'a joué
que 11 matches
donc c'est largement s'est largement
quelque chose d'envisageable pour moi en
nous avons une soit 5 et le choix vite
donc on va faire le simple enfin offert
dans l'ordre une équipe qui aime la
draft et des gens qu'on dénombre à john
hammond le gm d'orlando imposer une
amende
qu'est-ce qu'on a du côté de l'orlando
mais comme on doit forcément gardé quoi
alors toronto c'est quand même une
équipe qui est au stage 0 de sa
construction mais alors vraiment je suis
dur mais c'est la réalité du truc quand
ils ont tout fait péter la deadline
dernière c'est c'est clairement le but
c'est que d'ailleurs ils ont même pas de
coach d'ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est que
tu vraiment tutu reprend toutes les
fondations là tu as deux pics élevés le
5d lui tu l'as dis donc ça j'ai
l'impression que ça t'enlève étrangement
ça peut paraître antinomique mais ça
t'enlève la pression c'est à dire que tu
peux tenter des choses tu peux te
permettre de tenter
tu as un pic au talent un pique un peu
surprise un truc comme ça moi cette
équipe là alors oui tu peux regarder ce
qu'il ya dans l'effectif
tu peux regarder tu te retrouves avec
des gars yaris des tons poste de meneur
tu sais pas trop parce que marquer le
full ce toujours un peu pété parce que
parce que cole antony tu ta pas de
certitudes à tous les niveaux de façon
tu as besoin de quelque chose
moi je pense qu'il faut que tu draft au
talon
et au potentiel choisir les joueurs qui
dans deux trois ou cinq ans max seront
les plus forts possibles
ça c'est une directive r ça va donner du
côté du directeur sion draft si on draft
aux talents je suis j'ai juré je regarde
là ce que j'ai du temps devant moi
si on grafteaux sion sion dans jal est
nul il peut faire sens parce qu'il ya
une potentialité coming a pesé glisser
là aussi effectivement et ce que tu
balances et là je vois trois joueurs si
à deux pics je vois trois joueurs pour
de piquant fait potentiellement j'aime
bien book night mais c'est la céda c'est
pas évident c'est vraiment une question
d'une question de roster et de chantier
green green pour moi s'il encore dispo à
ce moment là ce qui peut arriver parce
qu'on est sur le cinquième choix ça
paraisse apparaît totalement logique
c'est un petit peu en difficulté face au
contact mais ses efforts dans le rail a
dû un contre un c'est un défenseur
convenable puis c'est quelqu'un qui peut
assez vite se projeter en nba je pense
après derrière à voir mais c'est c'est
ce qu'il perde surimpose 2,3 ça me
parait ça me paraît correct n'a pas de
prise de risque il on est sur du risque
calculé et récompense à la hauteur du
risque je pense et on sait vers convoi
écoute samba - poste 2-3 toute façon je
vous dis partout où tu as quoi tu as
garé un rythme on ne sait même pas s'il
va rester fatah je bois je suis preneur
du plus fort mais que sur un poste 2-3 a
fait un john green s'est vendu qui
jouait déjà angelides cette année qui a
réussi à scorer à scorer déjà alors
qu'il avait ses 18 points de moyenne
d'âge et des grègues chez quand même
c'est quoi un match correct à chantage
ouais ça peut être pas mal du côté
d'orlando n'ont pas tous au choix 6 ont
randonné reviendra pour le choix à 8 et
le choix si ce qui sera le premier de
beaucoup ne suis pas fou rire puisque
oklahoma à je ne sais plus incertain
pour partage de cette draft et donc ils
n'ont pas eu de chance à la loterie
ils se retrouvent avec le choix numéro 6
rémy alors là est ce qu'on continue à
empiler les talents et puis on jette
tout dans une marmite noir mais ça c'est
une bonne question c'est vrai qu'il ya
pas de pas de chance pour le coup d'une
se retrouve impliqué aussi ce après la
saison que tu as fait tu pouvais ce que
répliquer en un ou deux ou trois cette
année ou qu'ici c'était on va pas se
mentir c'est un centre de formation
c'était des espoirs qui joue et c'est
intéressant le groupe il est intéressant
mais c'est tellement jeune en fait tard
par un leader qui est clair claire c'est
celle d'alexander là dedans qui est le
joueur d'avenir de cette franchise
autour duquel tu construis
mais tata plein de mecs qui sont en
train d'éclore tu as le p'tit loup d'or
que moi j'adore ta beaucoup ces ch'tis
qui a monté des trucs tateo maledon qui
a été bon cette année les basly je
regarde s'il ya mauvaise brown c'est pas
mal
et en parlant de ses droits de douane
jamais départi a feeling of boston j'ai
pu enfin bon il avait fait éclore des
mecs là ils ont repris kemba walker
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on va faire
kemba walker moi je sais pas est ce que
ce qu'ils vont faire une crise paul
igamba walker ou est ce qu est ce qui
compte aussi contre le traité
immédiatement j'en sais rien donc faut
voir
coûte c'était une équipe qui manque
tellement de choses que moi je le draft
ferait à nouveau talent parce que j'ai
du mal à voir autre chose dans ta
construction tu draft aux talents si
possible un mec qui a un petit âtre et
si tu veux t'en servir pour le scoring
parce qu'en dehors de quettehou
d'alexander s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
scories dans cette équipe a le plus gros
talents disponibles le poste vraiment
j'ai l'impression qu'on pourra le faire
si tu es un peu n'importe où dans ce cas
là on est on est surbooké naito cumbia à
mon sens un coup il y a plus pour le
côté bon il ya le côté hype et le fait
qu'il était déjà en d-league cette année
puis il ya un vrai potentiel alors c'est
pas tout à fait finalisé il ya encore un
tir à 3 qui est en chantier s'élève au
delà du chantier à ce qu'on a 25 % sur
votre saison
sinon à bout knight ya une espèce
d'agents stories du scoring qui peut
mettre des gros tirs les choix sont un
peu compliquées c'est pas forcément
assez dans le catch une plaie mais dans
l'est dans les deux cas alors c'est des
profils très différents mais dans les
deux cas on est sur des joueurs qui
peuvent apporter des points qu il gâte
peut-être une dimension physique qui le
rend un peu plus un peu plus intrigante
ce qu'il a 2 3 de mondt envergure boktai
c'est un petit peu plus petits tout
dépend si on veut vraiment partir sur un
une question de passion veut partir sur
un 2 capable de scorer ou sur du 3 4 qui
vont qui pour moi finira forcément cadre
de toute façon avec peut-être des
questions sur les genoux
on est un petit peu entre les deux pour
moi c'est pas forcément pas forcément
simple de se décider sur thur sur ce sur
ce profil a éliminé scotty barnes du
court ce que tu barnes je vais me
tromper en disant ça mais scotty barnes
il a émigré dit je vois pas un upside de
fou mais je le vois dans une équipe aura
besoin de quelqu'un
prenons une équipe qui a forcé moins de
talent mais qui est un belle gueule
plutôt quelqu'un qui soit prêt à jouer
tout de suite et qui soit capable
d'apporter des choses différentes là si
on est si on est sur du c'ur du comment
dire sur du c'ur du potentiel sur du
talent sur du scoring
moi j'aime beaucoup barnes mai
c'est plus un joueur d'impact physique
qui est un joueur de volume à l'heure
actuelle que 15 joueurs capables
d'apporter sur le scoring
alors on va vraiment beaucoup mieux gaz
sur les postes 3 4 boutons facebook nice
si tu me proposes âgées plus tendance à
aller chercher un poste 3-4 même si on a
déjà dû pousser ce qui là dessous je
pense que comme un gars pourraient mieux
convenir de ce que je viens des romains
la pourpre au gros gros défenseur aussi
potentiellement mais il a déjà défendu
mes recettes
donc ok ici choix numéro 7 golden state
warriors il récupère le choix des
petites bourses mais bob myers rémy
quelle belle position et tu vas tu va
nous dire ce dont tu as besoin il ya
déjà des rumeurs de trade sur sur ce kit
pour améliorer le roadster immédiatement
est ce que ce serait mais l'option selon
toi ah oui oui là il y a des vrais choix
qui sont qui vont se poser à faire des
questions qui vont se poser cet été-là
poids dans les jours qui viennent
pour bob myers et des variances savait
que le sexe est une franchise un peu ses
franchises noble qui bosse bien qui
travaille dur depuis depuis des années
maintenant et qui a eu du succès mais
c'est une équipe qui est
traditionnellement à bosser sur le moyen
voire long terme qui a bossé
intelligemment
j'ai l'impression pour la première fois
depuis longtemps ils ont peut-être un
besoin d'urgence du fait du
vieillissement de ses stars en fait on à
cet effet que récré thompson je vais
faire mal du monde en disant ça mais je
ne sais pas les deux et la fenêtre de
tir pour essayer de retourner chercher
un titre avec ces deux là elle se réduit
tu vois donc le trade j'y crois fort j'y
crois fort fort fort ça parle de james
wyman beaucoup pour monter je serais pas
surprise si andrew higgins sortait aussi
dans les rumeurs dans les jours qui
viennent donc pourquoi pas monter dans
la draft pour aller chercher quelqu'un
si c'est pas le cas parce que bon pour
l'instant ce n'est pas prévu donc si
c'est pas le cas
j'ai l'impression qu'avec ces deux pays
qu'ils ont pas ce qu'ils vont piquer en
14 aussi donc c'est pas mal il faudrait
aller chercher quelqu'un d'aussi nba
reddick possible parce que pour la
première fois depuis longtemps ils ont
besoin d'un mec qui va les aider dès
cette année pour devenir un conteneur
or
pardon dans quels secteurs du jeu ils
ont besoin si on a quelqu'un de dispo
sur les postes arrières qui soit entre
dit je prends parce que steve que riquet
thompson
on voit bien avec les blessures qui sont
accumulés avec tout ça c'est plus enfin
si je peux éviter de les faire jouer 82
matchs à 34 minutes par match j'en
serais content from en haïti
b sens bon même s'il même s'ils vont
tout faire exploser siphon sea trade up
derrière ils ont soif avant sarah sera
la science fiction mais beaucoup d'ail
dans ce cas là par rapport à ce que tu
dis ça fait sens parce que c'est un
joueur qui sait du score de uconn alors
il ya peut-être pas forcément un plafond
très très élevé d'une polyvalence dans
ce corps est une tâche moins sont plus
que tu me dis là c'est bien un mec qui
soit qu'il soit on n'a pas besoin je
pense que là les variantes ils n'ont pas
de toit du nouveau cette écurie ils ont
juste besoin d'un mec qui peut venir en
rotation justement de sécurité thompson
et apporter ses quinze minutes 18
minutes dès l'an prochain
dans ce cas là dans ce cas là je pense
que book nights et c'est sûrement ça te
fera moins tu auras moins de temps
d'adaptation que sur certains profils
peut-être plus talentueux mais moins -
trait à l'heure actuelle donc dans
l'embout nice et tu as fait ça ça a du
sens à ce niveau là le yukon à golden
state en cours pour james goodnight donc
le sophomore des complices de
connecticut
on va finir avec le choix 8 on retourne
à orlando
rémy qui disait tout à l'heure la tête
dans la même optique qu'avec le choix
cinq talents et puis on envoie alors
c'est parce que c'est à vous j'ai pas
tous dotés je suis un très mauvais gm on
a pris quelques pixels du coup d'y aller
nous confiait ce qui est d'ailleurs un
bon pique je pense ont cinq écoutes faut
voir un petit peu ce qui est encore de
dispo en termes de talent là si on
prenait les trois quatre plus gros
talent en restant sur le bord de romain
tu proposes quoi comme le profil
m je ferai je ferai le jeu
quand ils barnes mois sur ce coup là
justement parce que pas forcément un
talent fou mes joueurs avec du volume
physique
il ya peut-être un peu de manque aussi
dans le secteur intérieur du côté du
côté d'orlando sur quelqu'un qui se font
un peu un peu dans la dureté un peu un
peu brut de décoffrage comme c'est de
faire à florida state ces dernières
années puisqu'ils ont sorti quelques
mecs sur ces profils là et ben barnes
sur barnes ont soit 8 ça me paraît pas
décollé
18dans 2,18 d'envergure sur le poste 4
bon j'ai dit un peu un pourcentage aux
lancers francs qu est pas génial une
main gauche a développé par contre il ya
un vrai sens de la passe donc il était
quasiment à dakhla de passes de moyenne
cette année donc il peut être aussi
facilitateur dans la construction du jeu
ça peut être ça peut être intéressant
d'une équipe qui qui se reconstruit
qu'il cherche à te voir un mec dg
efficace dans l'impact dans ces choses
là parce que c'est ce que c'est
intéressant en plus ce côté régional de
l'étape peut aider derrière donc moi ça
me paraît ça me parait ça me paraît pas
mal ça marche toujours et puis je
regardais un peu le roster de orlando la
saison prochaine
post 4 ça peut être intéressant parce
que le 5 il est il assez remplie on a
toujours moment baky et la ja wendell
carter qui arrivent et chicago là dans
les trade qui est qui et plus au fur et
à mesure sa carrière qui devient plus
15.4 j'ai l'impression remplir ce poste
4 pourrait m'intéresser
après après la solution isaiah jackson
mais c'est un peu plus bas derrière il a
des jackson mais après on est plus sur
dur dur dur du 5 4 sur 5 à 4 5 c'est un
peu il alliait jack isaac jackson tu ta
ta ta tu stretch pas du tout c'est
beaucoup beaucoup moins passeur donc
encore une fois après tout dépend de qui
va coacher ce qu'on veut sur un terme
aux rotations de jeu là on est sur un
poste 4 efficace physiquement mais qui
passe sa valve jackson c'est totalement
différent
c'est ça il ya quand même de l'up side
si le shoot arrive à se développer comme
si on sait qu orlando est pas la
meilleure franchise pour développer ont
découvert de ses prospects
c'est un joueur qu'on peut dire ça on
part sur scotty barnes on a les bons
deux côtés ok eh bien on va récapituler
kyle cunningham irait donc à detroit
evans au blé à houston john's à
cleveland
sharif cooper à toronto à orlando
john green ont donc scotty barnes avec
le 8 à oklahoma
on envoyait qing ming à la roma et james
mcknight apple downstate voilà le top 8
le soc 8 2 de la paire reverchon le roi
des décideurs actuels qui ont beaucoup
de beaucoup beaucoup de décisions à
prendre à part pour le premier choix qui
est un peu attendu sinon derrière il ya
quand même pas mal de suspense donc quoi
s'amuser le soir de la draft merci
beaucoup et oui tu as eu plaisir les
gars quand est ce que vous nous sortez
une race 1.0 là on a le big board déjà
donc une autre placement à nous répondre
les équipes et la mode draft devrait
arriver à devrait arriver sous dizaine
parfait parfait parfait et on bossera là
dessus pour bien merci romain gary et
puis habiter un taux tout le monde
évidemment vous renvoie si vous voulez
connaître tous les noms on a prononcé
dans cette vidéo
vers le site envergure pensé oh il ya
près 60 sous titré porte à l'heure où je
parle
il y en aura peut-être encore plus à
l'avenir donc blindés même pour les
prospects du deuxième tour vous devriez
être armés merci à tous
à bientôt et on se retrouve sur
envergure penser aux et en podcast chaos